hello everybody and welcome to part 7 of
let's play from dust
alright we're waiting on our guys here
to get here and they are taken forever
because they come from all directions
and all directions are far away ain't
that something
anyway they're almost there hopefully
the water will not kill them man that is
gushing out fast I should probably do
something about that I'm not stupid
enough to take sand from right there
actually would create a little drama
let's see what happened oh oh oh oh
run run guys oh that's not nearly as
threatening as I thought it'd be alright
anyway okay come on
okay five oh five uh-oh Oh No now you're
trapped
alright anyway I don't think there was
anything else um just look around yeah I
don't think so
oh no oh no okay better go now water's
coming water is a common okay I'm here
there we go
oh right moving forward there are only
so many levels in this game I'm
wondering if one of the problems that
people have with it was that it's really
short and maybe I don't know but as far
as I can tell I'm halfway through the
number of levels there are
and that one kind of urged me forward
because the water situation kind of made
it so that I had to move forward quickly
I didn't even get a chance to explore
deep way oh no that needle mama dick
oh hey poot on IG who's a macho ma ki
tarah beer moola Lackey ji Couture huh
bro
Blackie yeah this is gonna be a problem
I lost way too many villages to yeah
fire before and I felt very bad about
that so I have a feeling I'm going to
lose many more people not because I'm a
bad player but because well it's
probably because I'm a bad player okay
whoa what the oh oh no oh if that if
fire touches that that's gonna like
burst out water wow that is something Oh
that if freaky-looking there's a
specific fear that's like you're afraid
of think with a lot of holes in it I
forget what it is but if you've ever
seen a Lotus pod and got creeped out by
it you have that fear all right where am
I going only got six guys or so oh wow
just get get get two there oh man this
is gonna be a problem
oh wow don't touch the fire don't touch
the fire good you're not stupid all
right go go lady go all right I never
noticed that before you can hear them
panting oh I forgot you know whenever I
complained about them being so slow I
kind of forget that they're actually
running across the country at my beck
and call
so whatever thank you thank you guys and
gals oh that one's ear you can hear it
yeah
man that is like gigantic has got to be
like six stories tall and and I saw the
plant before it was miniscule as amazing
a lot of water alright anyway almost
there almost there come on now
anything I can do in the meantime this
looks bad the situation looks bad
cyclically burst into flames oh no there
goes oh oh no oh no all vegetation is
gonna crop up right by my village oh
it's gonna destroy it oh oh good thing
there's this water here okay I guess it
kind of protects it let me get some more
just in case oh man all right keep that
there for now I can always remove it
later
uh-huh found our village that's a
village oh okay
oh I get it oh that that would be so
much better because where it is is just
gonna not not not be good there we go
okay BAM and one of you guys go get this
thing
OOP but everybody whatever that is
probably another story that I don't
really know about I should check that
out
all right that one's gonna have to be
moved as well but I'm gonna let them
move that one okay um got more water
whole ocean here no lava that I can use
to terraform there's an oh how did I
miss that
Wow I'm stupid totem of fertility are
they all totems of fertility today I
just I don't know wait hey don't move on
me
nope this one's just total my fertility
let me get this one first cuz this one
can put out fire and I imagine that I'm
going to need that very very soon
all right get some more water let's see
what happens if I just doused this
nothing cuz it evaporates Wow good job
mark you're so smart
oh thank you me alright go go go go
little guys and girl girls always
leading the pack go woman go go go
oh whoa hey ho aah oh no oh you're okay
oh crap for help when you can help
yourself that's an important lesson my
friends let's see top of the mountain
anything on the other side that I'm
missing nope you're just a very cool
mountain oh I would love love to have a
level creator for this game that would
be very very cool all right almost there
need one more Oh everyone's waiting on
you slowpoke get in there get get in
there no excuses there you go help
that's freaky Oh but him just like that
just boom vegetation put a lot of
gardeners out of business also a lot of
home builders I wish I had a magical
drum that I could hang on and create a
cool house like that use story from the
memory powers okay the new power of the
breath extinguished fire okay Oh across
a whole map Wow
is something thank you very much aah aah
oh no aah put it put it out for there we
go
get out all gone just like that ok
what's this oh oh oh no oh no he's gonna
blow he's gonna blow
it's gonna blow isn't it oh oh all right
it looks fine okay I guess I was
panicking for nothing I'm really way too
used to playing horror games because I'm
ready for things to just jump out at me
and attack me and I'm ready to just
punch it in his face but I don't need to
and if I punch that thing in his face is
gonna explode everywhere area okay all
right to uproot a tree of water oh oh
okay
right okay uh then the wrestler does uh
okay all right okay so I take this and I
put it here all right cool okay oh
they're not scary at all they're useful
perfect
Oh than these would have protected my
village if that came by okay all right
cool I'm learning I'm learning
then I need these to go like right here
or something
boom oh just like that oh no oh no not
you okay yeah there we go okay if I put
this here bloosh perfect like it I like
it okay and I need to put one of these
no knots and give me you there we go
put them right here oh it's just like
that all down the mountain and then one
right curious I suppose now how about
one right in front of the fire things
I'd probably be smart you splitters oh
yeah just like that
ah Oh put out fire Oh for for for far
what happened to my defense oh no no no
no no put it all it's on cooldown oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
oh gosh that didn't do a thing oh that
didn't do anything
oh that didn't do nearly enough oh man
oh oh so sorry I feel so bad
I failed you I failed you all I failed
you why didn't these do anything right
there oh no here they go again
Oh bring it on oh they're ready you two
come in not San Heights and Gallagher oh
you okay and then okay that took care of
it that time I don't know what happened
last time oh there's more fire okay
these things need water okay mmm
oh yeah drink it up how am I gonna fill
those up again I better just move
forward quickly get here guys get air
get over here
right nerve and where's the last totem I
don't even see it seriously where is it
of like look everywhere I think over
there know what's going on I see four
totems ah okay not on fire ah don't
scream for help if you're not on fire oh
[ __ ] you're gonna be on fire don't go
that way
Tom don't go that way you're all going
that way do not oh my god don't die just
fire everywhere run away oh man you're
lucky you are lucky the vegetation grows
immediately it's the it's it's a stupid
vegetation that's growing that's causing
all the problems
alright get in there get that thing man
it is get this is actually starting to
be a problem just because there's so
much water now I don't have anything to
do with it I don't have evaporate yeah
hold on oh man okay I'm gonna man
all right there we go got that totem all
good
banging bang bang bang oh right out of
the ground okay okay oh there it is
okay oh thank you relocate the trees of
fire phenomenal
oh but Wow Oh jellify water okay
all right oh let me give me control I
see it oh it's beautiful panoramic okay
I get it
all right I got to cut it here thank you
guys so much for watching as always I
appreciate it and I will see you guys in
part 8 of let's play from dust bye bye